نحن عند نقطة تفتيش الدخول الأخيرة إلى
دوما التي تعد آخر جيوب المتمردين في
الضواحي الشرقية لدمشق الآن
ما نراه هنا هو عدة
حافلات مع ما نعتقد أنه
مقاتلين من المتمردين يخرجون من هذه المنطقة الآن
معظم هؤلاء المقاتلين.  في
اليومين الماضيين ، تم نقلهم بالحافلات إلى مواقع أخرى
معظمها في شمال سوريا ،
ولم تكن المجموعات التي رأيناها متأكدة من أي
جماعة متمردة تنتمي ، كما أنها لم تكن
متأكدة من المكان الذي سيتم نقلهم إليه ولكن في
الأسبوعين الماضيين  لقد
فقد المتمردون مساحة كبيرة من الأراضي
هنا في الضواحي الشرقية
لدمشق كانوا يسيطرون عليها في منطقة شاسعة ،
لكن بعد قتال عنيف للغاية
فر عشرات الآلاف من المدنيين من هذه
المنطقة ، ثم تم أيضًا إرسال
آلاف المقاتلين إلى الخارج أيضًا مع
المتمردين.
يعتقد الكثيرون أنه سيتم التوصل إلى اتفاق
قريبًا حتى يخرج هؤلاء المتمردون أيضًا ،
لكن من غير الواضح متى سيحدث ذلك بالضبط
ولكن يبدو أن هناك  أن نكون
أشخاصًا هنا في دمشق يعتقدون أنه
سيكون قريبًا جدًا في الواقع ، تحدثنا إلى
الأشخاص الذين أتوا إلى هنا إلى نقطة التفتيش هذه
وقلنا أن لديهم أقاربًا
تم اختطافهم خلف المتمردين
بعضهم لسنوات والذين يأملون أن
يخرجوا ، انظر فريد  كما هو الحال في سي إن إن شرقي غوته
سوريا